foreign
[Music]
midway between Orlando and Miami on
Florida's Atlantic Coast lies the small
town of Fort Pierce home to the
beachfront Inn and Inlet
owner Brian Paul opened it in 2012 after
running his family's successful local
fish market with his brother my job
before the inlet was the CEO the head of
my dad's fish market
my Dad ran a business like a uh a real
leader he had so many friends
pillar of the community everybody loved
him and I always knew as a child I
wanted to have my own place
[Music]
I think Brian has a lot of schooling
under his belt I'm not exactly sure that
he has any hotel experience
Brian as an owner is
physically here sometimes
he's just like kind of wanders around
Brian is a little too easy going if it
was me I'd have my hands nose eyes and
ears and everything and
I don't see him doing that
Brian definitely has a lot of friends
that work here some of which have taken
advantage of him in the past I believe
that Chef Ben probably has taken most
advantage of him
I want a beer
oh we're having a tasty beer tonight
boys
Ben is a uh an awesome guy I've known
him forever we've been friends forever I
give him plenty of space I help him
whatever he needs but I don't muddle in
his Affairs down there I think that the
issue here has been our lack of
consistency with our food and I mean
that directly has to be attributed to
the executive chef you know his name is
Ben
I feel like the inlet and the beachfront
both by act direction we're trying to be
too many things at once a nightclub a
bar a restaurant a hotel a wedding venue
a concert venue a place to do your
Christmas party at I mean ah the
military secret we have some guests and
employees hooting and holler until the
wee hours of the morning and that's out
of control that's got to stop it's bad
for business Brian has to refund hotel
guest money because of the noise
complaints
[Music]
I think this place has so much potential
and so much to offer we don't want to
see it fail we don't want to see Brian
fail he definitely needs to step up and
help us all out to help him he needs to
grab those reins and start start seeing
the damage that's happening and start
fixing it
today I'm in the beautiful coastal town
of Fort Pierce Florida just looking
around you're surrounded by stunning
beaches Marine is full of deep sea
fishing boats this place is gorgeous
it looks like the hotel is closed down
hello
anybody in welcome how are you I'm Veron
D thank you first name is Eliza Eliza
good to see you how are you doing today
who's is this the boss man caught it and
where's the other half gone maybe they
ate it a pair of shoes I couldn't tell
you it is it for I don't use it for
anything actually wow and what's that up
there that was here when I got here
believe it or not that's for sale
apparently so so he went onto the beach
picked up some Driftwood and then dipped
it in some varnish yep
22 dollars same as that one over there
no
insane no have you sold any of these
never
seriously and how much for the t-shirts
between twelve dollars for employees and
18 for guests so staff have to pay for
their own t-shirts yes and for the
guests they're 18 yes wow so when was
the last time you sold a t-shirt I sell
them every day but mostly to um the
employees employees yes how long you
been here the establishment's been here
almost three years I've been here almost
three years as well what's wrong with it
from your point of view noise levels you
know especially the one directly above
the restaurant that what kind of noise
because it's not the the music and the
people the foot traffic everybody
hanging out at the bar and things of
that nature so that goes on directly
underneath yes they end up being
refunded and then they end up putting us
on blast on all of these you know
websites and social media and just bad
reviews left and right
housekeeping I'm back
touch base with the housekeepers
I'm just out of interest it's Gordon
here I've just checked in how far away
are the [__] rooms I mean you sound
like you're miles away
hello Madam
you scared her so room 16. yes and where
is it please darling I'm going to direct
you right this way what's that thing
there we grill our wings on it you grill
your wings on it yes how often do you
grill wings in there every stinking day
wow Jesus in fact I think there's a Wing
left in there
when was that grilled chances are it
could have been yesterday those are the
extra crispy ones and who's responsible
for this
the kitchen handles all of this end of
it of course you found another
charbroiled and these were done
yesterday I believe so and they cook
every day on here yes I know the
customer's still alive
[__]
right room 16. this is your Caribbean
building the Caribbean
Caribbean Caribbean yes uh-huh what part
of this resembles the Caribbean I think
it's more so because of the view oh the
view right here sir thank you very much
you're very welcome enjoy thank you
thank you wow
oh
stinks in here there's a very sort of
damp musty smell bloody hell
oh the bed feels like it's 15 years old
really bad
absolutely disgusting
180 divide for this [__] all
ugh
wow mini bar
consisting of absolutely [__] freezer
over Frozen and defrosted about 10 years
ago what a mess
[Music]
I know when I'm coming to fix a business
they have various issues but right now
with the information I have I am not
impressed with how Brian as an owner is
operating this hotel
hello hello welcome to the inlet so you
must be Brian I am so the hotelier and
the 34 year old I do it all you do it
all
is that what you are seriously 34 right
you know what I'm 33.
I work so hard I think I just thought I
was 34. you're 33. hey
um did you call this building the
Caribbean yes have you ever been to the
Caribbean yeah which part uh Bahamas and
this has been modeled on the Bahamas
correct do you smoke when you're in the
Bahamas you know like that I've tried a
couple times surely stop yeah yeah and
that's what hotel in the Caribbean or
the Bahamas were you running before you
bought this one so I've just visited the
Caribbean I've never ran a hotel in the
Caribbean so you just go buy yourself a
25 bedroom hotel on the beach with a bar
and all I know how to do is run a fish
market when I open this and I shot it
from the scratch from the ground up it's
the fish it's fresh obviously from the
market they're so fresh right I better
jump in can I show you Turtle uh yes why
not yeah
foreign
I'm excited for the fresh fish
this is so surreal bro Gordon Rams and
dining room that's with the main tax I
mean you're the owner right I think I
should lead by example so I I like to
wear mine that way if I tell them that
they need to wear them then they can't
say well Brian you don't wear yours
right I'm starving I'm gonna give you
some food right away I'm gonna get you a
great server okay grace
[Music]
Kelly how long you been here um I've
been here about a year nice and um why
do the staff have to buy the t-shirts um
I don't I was never told even our first
shirts our name tags you buy your name
tag as well yeah
we have to pay like eight dollars never
seen it before eight dollars a name tag
twelve dollars a t-shirt that's twenty
dollars a week of the [__] work
wow
as I look at the menu I notice it's
absolutely massive so I decided to order
the chicken wings which honestly I
wasn't surprised when they were dry
then I had the lobster mac and cheese
which technically isn't mac and cheese
because they use penne pasta but the
worst part of my lunch was the tuna
burger which I knew wasn't quite right
is that fresh
it is frozen oh it's frozen yes
hold on you said Fish Market Fresh Fish
daily
frozen fish fresh fish what's going on
we use frozen sometimes sure and you
have a fish market that you buy from
yeah yep yeah
um I'm confused ever since about four
months ago everything was fresh
everything I ran up a little bit of a
bill with my brother so we cut back and
started ordering some of the Frozen
stuff from some of the purveyors and
what's the feedback we get some negative
feedback
he hasn't had one nice thing to say I
know it's I'll blow to the ego but
you knew it was gonna be something I
think it was me everything
um explain this monstrosity what in the
[__] is going on here
this is our kiosk chaos and after that
products for all sorts of people so
volleyballs volleyballs uh beans stick
bags
how busy is this how was it going I
honestly uh it doesn't do that good how
many beach towels have we sold not too
many beach towels show me one all right
I'd love to see one please
what a [__] disaster
we're on the beach we don't have towels
what is wrong with this picture how was
lunch
okay okay it's not good enough
I thought we lost you
thank you very much whenever you're
ready to go to the beach whatever I'm
ready to go to the beach wow how did you
have to stop
one
you got it
still okay can you charge out to my room
please yes sir so we sold out now
yes yeah
wow
jeez
[Music]
at lunch I was very disappointed that
Brian falsely advertises fresh fish on
his menu I want to learn more about how
involved he is as an owner during an
evening at the beachfront checking in
Susan Addison can I go ahead and start
you off with something to drink okay
smoke them if you got him
uh just give us a little quick run
through how the line works well normally
I run the pass in Expo Chef I'll take
care of this boom boom boom usually the
passenger the saute guy and then the fry
guy working with Ben I can't really tell
you what he does where's Brian
don't know chef and Brian would just
avoid him instead of trying to get to
the root of the problem and I think that
in itself is a problem
how long have you been here uh since
last December oh wow so you've been here
a long time yeah in your mind what do
you think the major problems are lack of
consistency as a matter of fact and lack
of structure yeah I saw it at lunch time
yeah I found out about the fish not
being so fresh how can you not sell
fresh fish when you're on the beach
that's our motto fresh fish
so how many do you think understand that
we're selling frozen fish they probably
don't no because I don't think the
servers are telling them meanwhile the
customers disappear yeah thank you great
update thank you
Brian how many of these customers in
tonight know that you're serving frozen
food you know they don't really know how
the uh the market works so probably none
of them I don't know how the market
Works they don't understand how are you
good how are you do you think we'll be
serving frozen food tonight or fresh
fish fresh fresh why fresh
well why don't you explain to him
tonight that you change things four
months ago and we're not serving fresh
fish anymore we're serving Frozen
man up so uh just a few months ago we
switched from some of our fresh product
to some of Frozen Seafood products why
would you do that they're quality
products they just aren't the best the
quality that you would expect from you
know the Pelican seafood market they're
quality Frozen products yeah it's a cost
thing so
good
this is the Frozen bit here what's that
Frozen avocado are we not in Florida
and you can't make fresh avocado
dude this is [__] where's the freezer
main walking
wow wow wow when was the last time you
were in here I come in here once a week
at least and I want someone to you know
just kind of look around or whatever
what is this
wow
oh man
look at that the water's gone slimy and
you come in here once a week yeah
what is that
oh boy
ow what is that
pina colada
pina colada why it's like that I have no
idea it's faster it's it's off it's
bubbling
oh man that's terrible [__] trash please
trash
James I'll do trash please now pina
colada right down the drain by the
bucket load in the walk-in fridge
I mean who in the hell off price like
this
Gordon this is Chef Ben's job he's the
executive chef he's the executive chef
and you've made him that Executive Chef
Ryan sure I did
how'd you feel now
what's that tuna burger that's from the
burger yes it is oh my gosh seriously
bacon it's gone it's it's off fresh
produce on top of old produce moldy and
this one ribeye rib eye defrosting what
is this those are the smoked grilled
chicken wings before they go onto the
char grill oh my God and what is in this
one
you are kidding me
so underneath in that bucket is what
cooked product cooked chicken and on top
of it is what
it's raw raw chicken on top of cooked
chicken I had them for lunch
I am at a [__] loss do you know the
best way out of this is just to shut the
place down
it's not an option for me
what's that in there Ben those are
marinated chicken wings yeah underneath
next box
there's our smoke rule number [__]
one
Ben
I know Chef I didn't do it
you know I turn my back for a minute and
this is the kind of [__] that happens I
walked in and it was bedlam
[Music]
he's telling me this is your fault
you've got no idea I am at a absolute
[__] loss
I can't work like this this is huge you
now are running a restaurant cross
contaminated
[Music]
Joey yeah Chef who's responsible for
this
um we all are the entire kitchen is yeah
rule number one if you can't put hot
food in the [__] walking it doesn't
even go together no no no we're near
each other I guarantee you when it was
put in there after I marinated it they
weren't shuffled
I can give you 12 more issues in there
that I've had I mean you are heading for
a [__] massive disaster
I mean who the hell put them on top of
the the other ones everybody in here
goes back haven't you trained everybody
to know that I mean
all I'm getting right now is excuses the
kitchen needs direction from the chef
the staff need direction from the owner
and your buddies can someone come up
with a [__] solution
I'm gonna go in 86 the wings sort it out
quickly
come on guys
86 Wings someone put raw [__] chicken
wings on top of cookies it wasn't me
somebody else did it 86 Wings is the
only thing I can do right now what in
the [__] is going on I was baffled in a
maze the words out of Ben's mouth were
oh I cleaned that cooler regularly every
day
[Music]
you want me to go in there and pull
everything out clean it that is not your
job to wipe the ass an executive chef I
I know that
but maybe three days a week
why didn't Brian step up Brian he may be
oblivious to some of this stuff they've
known each other since they were young
guys so you know this is crazy so Ben
goes AWOL Brian does nothing about it
the place starts falling apart and then
he just step [__] when he wants
pretty much pretty much but if this was
your business you wouldn't tolerate that
yeah
I was all for foreign
no excuse for that walk-in like that so
I'm sorry I just couldn't hold back
anymore he doesn't he doesn't come to
work that's the reason why it looks like
that okay that is absolutely the reason
why
if he's here by 12 and he leaves by five
we're lucky
I'm just I'm not sure he's just telling
me the truth I'm I'm I'm here to tell
you the truth you're not telling me this
I promise you I'm going to tell you the
truth the only way to really truly
identify a chef before you even taste
these foods to open up he's walking that
speaks volumes for any chef he's a chef
that's given up and going through the
motions sometimes I feel that way we've
been through a lot I know he's got a lot
on his place he's incompetent and he's
taking your [__] business down
you know I don't think he's incompetent
you [__] mess and the sad thing is
that your staff and your management and
your team see it and you're the only
person that doesn't know what's going on
and this is the way you want to run your
business yeah oh you do not need my help
[Music]
I swear
what's up funny people
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that's loud that music it is loud oh
man how are you doing yeah I just need a
little piece of quiet
um
that's crazy no yes it is I mean it's
like the blind leading the blind in
there because there's no discipline
yeah I do now Ben's checked out Brian's
never checked in and uh they're all
blaming each other yeah I do know
there's no there's no discipline there's
no communication there's none of it no
what's the problem with him stepping up
and
dealing with issues maybe it has
something to do with the fact that he
he's not fully
experienced in certain departments are
they hosting concerts are they uh is it
a frat party hangout is it a college I
mean how can they call themselves a
hotel that's that's the difference
that's the part that we need to try to
separate and I've been saying it for a
while yeah I'm sorry excuse me good
evening beach front end Liza speaking
how can I help you
highlight
s room 20
[Music]
does and it smells like smoke and uh my
my friend here Gloria is having a really
bad reaction
steroids and it's supposed to be a
non-smoking room
I'll be right with you
Brian there's two guests have checked in
upstairs okay
uh she's uh she's got an issue with
analogy because the room stinks of smoke
it'd be nice to just come up and see
them or try and calm the situation now
so the lady's got an allergy and she's
already had to take a steroid and her
eyes are streaming and she's not very
happy okay hello hello so are you okay
yeah I'm fine sure any issues
sorry we had water all over the floor
we've also all over the floor
refrigerator there's water on the floor
oh no really I just cleaned it up with a
towel yeah I'm sorry
damn I walked out it was completely all
the way to the bed
Wow Let's uh let's come back to school
system the ladies her eyes are streaming
do excuse us ladies
are you decent
sorry I've got the owner here
oh really
yeah
oh [__] there you go it's just my eyes
are tearing when was that cleaned last
that's a uh that's really a daily thing
that um daily it should be sure yeah
absolutely that is not daily uh look at
that
that's why
Jesus
as you can see
now one of the poor ladies broken out
like the back of my throat is all
scratchy is there an alternative room we
can use for ladies I'll double check
right away have a drink downstairs a
little bite to eat but we can sort
something out
the big problem here is that there's no
direction for the hotel for the
restaurant for the Gazebo not even for
the car park Ben is like a headless
chicken that's checked out and Brian's
like this scared school kid that is not
qualified to run a [__] beach bar let
alone a hotel on a beach so
this is bad
this is really Grim
Ryan am I wrong I feel like we blew it
tonight oh man that's just this is what
it is you know we'll uh don't worry
about it
[Music]
oh for God's sake
after a very frustrating night I woke up
this morning hopeful that Brian would be
eager to admit his faults at the
beachfront
that wasn't the case even after a staff
meeting none of the problems are sinking
in with Brian so I reached out to his
brother Eric who is continuing to fund
the business and I'm hoping Brian can
start to see the damage he has done
guys thanks for coming in
well as Ramsey here
your brother just asked you a question
why did you call me here I've got uh a
lot of issues that I need to take care
of you don't look like a man that's in
pain you don't look like a man that's
struggling you don't look like a man
that's lost control you look like you're
bouncing around having fun the business
is hurting you're hurting your brother's
business and you're not realizing it it
does reach a ceiling where where Brian
you're gonna have to get cut off
I will I'll respect it but you gotta let
me know how much time and I'll I'll make
it I'll make it
two more months and then that's it
two months
here's my promise
I will focus so hard and I'll be able to
pay you in eight weeks
I'll pay you in eight weeks I'll pay you
in eight weeks
30 grand
you gotta You You You Gotta Give me you
got to give me 90 days I mean you got to
give me 90 days
he's just giving you eight weeks you
just asked for 12 weeks
you can't continue depending on your
little brother's cash
float your dreams
I just need you to make sure not to
screw this one up again
I'm not gonna screw it up
I'm not convinced
no no no you're lucky he's your [__]
brother
Eric I got you eight months eight weeks
eight weeks are cut off that's all there
is to it man
how important is your reputation to you
that's the most important thing in my
world and on a scale of one to ten your
reputation in this town now I gave
myself a good a good eight a good eight
good good strong age absolutely so these
are customers that have gone out their
way to spend their hard-earned cash
supporting your business you must
recognize a few of these faces
absolutely I do let's start off with the
lady in the blue shirt you know her very
well hey play hi Brian how'd you know
each other I'm Mark at Bryan you're a
spokesperson for that business yes can
you be honest with this one yes I can
the service is very
bad
I've brought people here I've been up at
the bar myself trying to order even just
a water that's been tough
do you not listen to the advice in terms
of sloppy service
I I absolutely I listen I do listen I do
listen I do listen do you offload that
to your team
no I don't I don't so that's why he's
not dealt with
sir your experience we ordered our
chicken sandwich when the chicken
sandwich came out it was raw it was
wrong it was mushy in the middle I could
have got sick from that
and I love your bar because I could come
here late night and I can get free
drinks so for me and two for my buddy
and paid for one we got five
wow
unbelievable so my first experience here
was a Super Bowl party that you
advertised and actually had some out of
town guests food was very mediocre the
crab cakes were like sawdust they were
horrible that night after the game was
over a couple Rowdy fans started a
little brawl we had drinks thrown on us
wow the other thing I'd like to say is
if I'm staying on the ocean I love to
fall asleep with the window open and
hear the ocean
you can't do that here you hear music
all night long
I honestly stayed here myself once I
tried to call down because our sheets
were dirty you couldn't even call like
nobody answered and literally I think
the biggest problem for me is the mixed
message it's like are you a bar or are
you a restaurant because they're paying
150 for dinner however there's people
walking in in bikinis drunk
yeah
listen this feedback has been crucial
anything you'd like to say
thank you guys you guys rock man thank
you I'm telling you make you proud I
promise you
let's go
it's not a time for high-fiving I'm
[__] embarrassed what the [__] you
hugging them for I know that they care I
do know they care a raw chicken sandwich
but that's not an
that is not an eight out of ten and do
you think they're set up do you think
this is a TV show Norm we're just gonna
spout off these people aren't
exaggerating they're real they're real
customers
you're turning into a laughing stock
yeah I know it's not good the jury's out
with me I've never come this far and
still sat on the fence in an undecided
way but [__] listen up and listen
carefully the partying the free-for-all
I'm paying for one drink they're giving
me five
in front of your eyes
tomorrow
you turn up here looking like an owner
understood you got a lot on your plate
but get your head out the [__] clouds
and get real
[__] off I've got this Gordon
I'll show you
even though I wasn't won over by Brian's
commitment I went ahead and designed a
new concept for the beachfront
my team and I completely overhauled the
rooms and added a beach club to the
unused outdoor space I'm really hoping
Brian can see the potential he has to
offer
morning good morning well I wish it was
a good morning what did I ask you to
come into work today what did I say was
the one thing I said to you come in as a
boss a boss
right now
you look like a towel boy
I mean sunglasses around your neck
badge on there shorts on there who are
you give me the name badge
[Music]
stand out from the crowd you're the
owner
I've had a really rough night and so is
my team get out of here get changed and
come back like an owner now [__] off
ready
honestly
hurry up no no no no no no I'm not
listening
Gordon I'm coming back like a boss I'm
ready to make this whole Fort Pierce
Community proud Gordon get out of there
seat belt on
no doors and no seat valve oh my God
[Music]
I'll be back I'll be back I'll be ready
Brian returned looking like an owner and
I'm hoping that translates into his role
as a boss let's go Joey Quick Step let's
go it's time to reveal to Brian and his
staff the newly renovated beachfront Inn
and Inlet oh my God
first of all this is not the spring
break hangout that's gone wrong this is
a proper beach front room sweet
oh yeah so Inlet oh my God whoa the
floor I love it it's perfect but you've
got a tangible asset here that can help
lift this business and more importantly
start making money awesome Brian you
need to get a grip of this business and
you need to realize you know what's at
stake here I need to be convinced I need
to see you stepping up as a boss Ben and
Jerry we're relaunching that Russian
tonight so I'm gonna go through that
menu jump downstairs get organized and
start finding your way let's go
oh man
after observing dinner service
I saw the beachfront kitchen wasn't set
up to handle such a massive menu so I
redesigned a smaller menu that is easy
for Ben to execute
okay guys small menu let's run from the
top appetizers lobster mac and cheese
done with the correct pasta Ben steamed
Lambs again great showing for the table
Wings off the smoker so it stays nice
and crisp
and a chicken cobb salad entrees pan
seed scallops easy three says ahi tuna
fresh and then of course the Mai Mai
it's small it's inviting and tonight
I've just been told that we've got the
mare in for dinner there's one person we
can reach out to to send the message
back in the community this is it
dig in
that sauce is fabulous oh my God
wow
it's time to relaunch the beachfront I
put a plan in place and I'm really
hoping Brian can finally show me that
he's ready to run his business all right
everybody listen up
tonight is a big service there's not
many opportunities like this
you have to take advantage of it I need
you guys all to get together right now
and bring it in one two three
Prime Brian let's just get real for a
couple of seconds yeah yes sir you
forgot the [__] most important thing
tonight
who is in for dinner tonight you haven't
even told the staff possibly the most
important person in this town we have
the mayor in the night you guys the
mayor and that's just not something that
happens every [__] week you have to
bring it together tonight you have to
work as a team sort out guys we're
opening in five minutes
come on
[Music]
checking in all right welcome to the
inlet good evening good evening this is
lovely
um enjoy dinner an amazing array of
appetizers and the entrees are to Die
For Tourists in the hair slow and steady
wins a race
so first they get on yes good
Hi how are you welcome hi guys okay
yeah now why are you sitting here
well they were gonna they were gonna
give it a choice we'd like to sit inside
of our side it's her choice
welcome how are you thank you for coming
in thank you guys it's an absolute
pleasure I'll leave you in hands of our
manager owner Brian follow me guys
welcome back good to see you sir
likewise
okay guys
all right mayor wherever you like inside
I got a chicken burger ready at your
leisure chicken burger
spent as Brian told you the medicine no
no he has not I'm real
yeah Brian
your Chef doesn't even know the mayor's
in ah you don't think he deserves to
know because he does come on man Ben yes
the mayor's in at table seven period
table seven
am I good Ben
I've got that blackened chicken for you
and that's it Ben you need to be the
captain and right now
I'm not convinced let's get serious
about this business and do this is the
men's order in
are they sending advertisers yet are
they yeah they hit the table no I put
their food in he wanted the salad and
the fried calamari and she wanted the um
okay great so again check in that's a
hot ticket tonight but do you know
what's happening in your kitchen at the
moment no look at me do you know what's
happening in there you haven't got a
[__] clue yeah get into the kitchen
find out what's going on let's go
behind you
wow that burnt my forehead
excuse me
so what did you guys order
um I got the mahi mahi and a salad and
he got an appetizer
the mat is the only person sat with
nothing in front of her okay please
all right two Tunis
can I have a table 15's appetizers ASAP
it's the mayor 15 15. I was told seven
sorry miscommunication it sat on 15
right I made a mistake okay I need two
house salads right now before anything
else right this second
Ryan didn't know what table the mayor
was at
it seems like the biggest thing Brian
changed was his wardrobe two houses are
in the window two house
and you can see everything he's doing
there Terry it's too much dressing bro
redo it sun is overdressed soggy as [__]
wrong dressing yes sir all I need to
hear is a bit of a voice if we go silent
we'll go down
[Music]
for tonight's relaunch of the Beast
front Salas overdressed soggy as [__]
wrong dressing I was really hoping Brian
would step up as an owner given that I
put everything in place for him to
succeed
oh damn it dude but his lack of focus
has me really worried that he's not fit
to run this place
your Chef has shut down I didn't realize
that you didn't realize so the first two
sellers for the mayor had the wrong
dressing on and were overdressed I said
if you taste them he said no so he
hasn't got your back when's that Penny
gonna drop that you're gonna turn the
corner
I will watch Ben if he doesn't come out
of it we'll switch him and Joey
will you
how many guacamoles you guys got out
there
okay okay
hey check in 30 seconds
give me time on the mess table please
Ben table 15 yeah the mass type we sold
it calamarina Mahi did you see it before
he went I sure did I played it
everything
the man hasn't got a [__] thing
Ryan
urgently come here
so Ben's told me the [__] Mare's got
their food and look at the mayor's table
there's nothing on there look at me look
at look now hey we're about to go down
yeah and I'm gonna get in my [__] car
and I get the [__] out of it if you
don't get a grip because this is a
[__] joke now you better get in there
and tell your executive chef then that
the mayor hasn't got their food and find
out where the [__] it is
Ben the mayor's not gotten her food I
put it in the window where where is it
I'll make it right now I'll make it
right now
[Applause]
it might be nice to have some food let's
try the mayor's food again
what is that undercooked that is
undercooked
what's that chicken look like to you
thank you so it's dry
um good lady how would you describe that
chicken
it looks kind of dry very dry there you
go you're not even a chef are you no no
I'm 20. thanks darling so from a 20 year
old Service never cooked even she
spotting is dry and you're saying it's
raw let me tell you something and listen
carefully I'm going I'm packing my bags
it's that it's the worst thing we've
sent all week it's overcooked and it's
dry and then you you tell me it's raw
good night
I'm done
is unreal I mean I'm so pissed off I
can't give that guy
any more advice I can't continue to tell
him to step up and make decisions
he has a chef in there that's just
riding him and riding the business and
when you're weak you've got no chance of
running a business
and what a shame
um [__] real
all right coming around
I never like to leave a business but
Brian simply wasn't listening he missed
the deadline paying his brother back and
while it's been a slow process my advice
finally started to sink in four months
after I left he made a decision to let
Chef Ben go and hired a brand new
kitchen staff on the hotel side Brian
has made the guess a priority given the
curfew to the nighttime entertainment
hopefully now with Brian stepping up
like a boss he can lead the beachfront
in the right direction
[Music]
when I first came into the area I saw
this piece of land it was right next to
one of the world's best fly Fisheries
the Henry's Fork of the Snake River and
we jumped right on that piece of
property and started building the lodge
I thought I could fly fish while I had
the phone in my pocket taking
reservations
and that actually happened early on in
the early days in 1999
[Music]
fill the logs sometimes he'd make our
sons peel some logs but they were pretty
pretty little growing up here was
something
special we literally worked every aspect
of it I started out as a little kid
doing dishes and busting tables and then
waiting tables when we finally got the
lodge built and opened would have like
two hour wait
people loved it loved it the lodge was
full every single night it was going so
well that they were getting ready to
expand and then that summer we lost my
little brother he was 10 years old when
he died
[Music]
it was it was dark it was dark bad time
and my mom fell out
[Music]
when we lost that little boy our life
it's stopped
and I went to bed for three years
and I didn't I didn't get up
so without her here my dad was forced to
run everything by himself and that's
kind of the way he coped with everything
there was just a darkness and a sadness
that surrounded our family for years
business is quite slow I'd say it's
probably 25 percent compared to 100 back
then
David needs some help
that came back about a year ago to help
me run the restaurant and Lodge
he sees constantly how it's a struggle
for me to keep up with the restaurant
side so he came back to help
you take a young man you stick him in
there and you put him as a general
manager a general manager in my opinion
is somebody who needs to know the inside
and outside of the whole operation but
he doesn't know these things
Dave and I are tired and it's just like
a black hole for us and we don't want to
work this hard anymore
making a comeback is our last hope it's
my best hope
[Music]
I've just arrived at Island Park Idaho
and it is absolutely gorgeous this city
is nicknamed last chance because it
literally is the last place to stop for
food gas and lodgings before entering
Yellowstone National Park
and this location is one of the most
prestigious fly fishing areas anywhere
in the world it's a Fisherman's Paradise
Place go wrong look at that gorgeous
hello Hi how are you good Savannah
Gordon nice to see you me too wow
my goodness me this place is gorgeous
who built it my father no stop yeah
seriously their hands you are kidding me
wow yeah it's all family business we're
all doing it together wow um and
recently my oldest brother Zach took
over the restaurant so Zach's the
restaurant manager there's mum and dad
around I'd love to meet them oh I'll
follow you
wow look at those Beauties up there it's
a vegetarian nightmare up there yeah
let's fish everywhere yeah for real
Hello
Preston good to see you guys wow this is
definitely a family-run business right
yes sir Gordon how are you the gentle
Giants with the Midas touch by the looks
of things congratulations this place is
gorgeous thank you thank you did you
build it really I did build it wow just
had a vision in my mind and we put
things up took them down until it looked
great and do you live on the property
hey do we have a cabin right across the
way just here yeah don't tell me you
built that as well I did
where was the conversation you both had
when you decided to go ahead and build
it we found this all beat up buildings
there was a for sale sign on the back
side of it so we've made a deal and here
we are started building and what was the
dream Diddy what was the ambition well
you know we just love love the beautiful
River we just started with boom
boom right and people just loved it so
there was like a two hour wait every
night how long ago was that that was our
first two years wow like our first two
years that was a long time ago so we got
off to a great start what happened then
we had another chef and then people got
mad because we changed the menu after
that we had a tragedy
after the tragedy my parents
just kind of checked out it was a really
hard time for my family and I think it
showed in the lodge you know they
couldn't put their whole heart into it
because their heart was broken so are
you in love with it as much today as you
were 10 years ago I
I'm very proud of it and I love it
right we've been here a lot
our goal is to have the best restaurant
in the area and then 100 miles around
but through the years we've just lost
interest in that and he's really tired
you know he doesn't want to work that
hard in right
so you're the Russian manager yes and
where did you train I worked at a few
really nice places when I was living in
San Diego that was where I probably
learned the most I see he went away and
then came back I've been gone for about
nine years yeah right okay I'm gonna get
to the room and pack um sat why don't
you show me to the room yes sir
it's kind of stinks no what's that smell
of lemon I'm not sure smell of lemon
I mean why on Earth would you need air
freshener in here with such beautiful ah
woof
yes the smell in here is crazy you know
let me just clearly up the window I
guess the back of your throat right yeah
um someone gonna make up the beds they
are made I've seen dog baskets uh better
how old are they they put in about five
years ago bloody hell seriously yeah
they're definitely old
is that blood I don't think so what is
that
I'm not sure it's a stain anyway wow
okay so
um I'll be down in a couple of minutes
for a bite to eat sounds great yeah
would you recommend she does the rainbow
trout here what's her name her name is
Gina okay great thanks for updates
thanks Zach
wow
the view is breathtaking
but the color is depressing I mean
honestly everything's dark and gray and
dingy and the pillows look at those how
uninviting like the dog sat on it for
the last 10 years really do smell
what is that
it's like a piece of candy stuck on the
pillow
terrible it's almost like they've fallen
out of love
for this place and look at that oh big
dirty stain it's sad because it's almost
on the verge of being neglected and
you've got two owners that have clearly
run themselves into the ground you think
of a lodge in this area you think of
something that's cozy it's warm in
biting this is depressing oh dear
always a great way to find out how often
the place is cleaned
check out the filters
that's
that's 15 years of dust
that's in there turn this thing off
it doesn't take much to clean that
hence the reason why this room stinks
of air freshener
[Music]
um
this is Gina Gina hey how are you oh so
nice to meet you nice to see you too
what do you think is wrong with the
business
staffing issues servers they're just
constantly late and you know I wouldn't
have a manager but Zack's a manager yes
he would come in at three or four
o'clock hey afternoon yeah what is that
day's fault is he tied uh does he not
want to put money into the business he
wants to be as Thrifty as possible yeah
you know this is your menu right you're
the chef so yeah I know so who dictates
this
Dave he never let anyone do the food
orders even no chefs but he's
controlling you yes and controlling the
business tightly by the sounds of things
yeah Gina thank you thank you
does your dad realize when you build
something this unique then you need to
have a team to run it I don't think so
no I don't think he realizes at all he
doesn't know he doesn't know one bit
he's not he doesn't let them order their
own food ah no she watches every penny
is he that controlling he really wants
to watch what's being sent out and
what's being paid for the money
Zach please
excuse me thank you sir my pleasure
thank you very much
wings are for you sir with the homemade
very barbecue sauce wow thank you are
the wings fresh
I believe they come Frozen
yeah you can't buy fresh chicken locally
here
Bean served frozen food wasn't the start
I was looking for it looks like it's
been
dipped in else blood in fact the food
just kept getting worse pulling back
that rib eye is like pulling back that
duvet on my mattress that's stain and
and strong in alcohol these are good
wine for this right all right
Gina claims her hands are tied in the
kitchen so at this point I don't know
who to blame
mush
who Could That
goat meal what the [__] Idaho rainbow
trout with the herb risotto Jesus
what's all the uh squidgy bits around
the outside those are all the sauces all
the sauces yeah yeah seriously yeah
ah is that risotto or some of the
plaster that your dad left over from
building the new Lodge
it's still got the scales on it as well
why would you leave the skin that's
soggy like some news condom
that has to be the worst trout I've ever
seen in my entire career
wow does Mom and Dad see this food do
they come and have dinner they hate
everything they hate the
the dish or everything
they don't like the way that she does
anything and why is she here when you're
in the heat of the Season we kind of
just take what we can get you can't keep
on changing your Chef every year I agree
we do it every year [__] you now
if this place wasn't run by your parents
would you work here hell no not not for
a second I don't want to run a
restaurant how can I need to get out I
I'm desperate
and if you got a job tomorrow would you
be off
yeah I feel like I've kind of done my
part the part that I told them that I
would do you're obviously concerned and
you're doing it more out of affection as
opposed to you really want to be here
sounds like your mind's made up
mm-hmm
[Music]
let's get them out please
come both of us did you come out
also yeah what if I don't want to
Jeff Ramsey nice to meet you likewise
good to see you too
wow uh so I'm not for words
what feedback did you get throughout my
lunch
I didn't see anything you didn't say
words nothing at all not yet course by
course you didn't even talk to them no
why not I figured that was what you were
going to do when we were done I was
hoping at least you're gonna say
something to them so they can up the
game no I actually expecting you to say
something and I thought well should I
ask or I kept thinking okay must be okay
I haven't heard any comments
don't you want the truth oh absolutely
do you know the owners hate your dishes
no you don't know the owners hate your
food no I did not know that you've got
no idea that Dede can't stand the curry
no I never knew that
I feel like people have been lying to me
Tina I don't blame her let me I'm going
to be frank
everybody was overcooked it looked like
we'd opened up the bottom of the
dishwasher and that plug was blocked
with bits of floating Grease
you may find it funny but you're not
sure it was funny the way you just
described no but art I know I'm not
trying to laugh about the river no no
but [__] now
look where we're sat though if you phone
me on my telephone in the car and ask me
what do you think I'm gonna be having I
would have never mention those dishes
you did nothing to blow me away I'm
trying to use the ingredients that Dave
asked me to use a lot of it is cost so I
was tied to that
oh you're the sous chef is there any
Synergy in what you're doing no
you're just doing it to survive no one's
thinking long term
it's stifling the business
I'm amazed you're still open
Zach I don't know if you've got one foot
in one foot out you shouldn't be here
yeah I've not been super invested that's
for sure get the [__] out of here
[Music]
hi
so far I've learned that Dave and Dede
are checked out and Zach just doesn't
want to be here tonight a dinner service
I'm curious to see if Dave is actually
holding Gina back in the kitchen
um
so Gina explain the line don't stop
working okay I work right here in the
saute area
section doing the burgers the steaks and
Zach he mostly stands behind the bar so
he's not the restaurant manager then
he's the barman he's supposed to be
he went from the bottom to the top this
summer nothing in between but you don't
get support from him doesn't know how to
doesn't have to
what's the microwave for Gina uh to heat
the dip up not my choice but not my
choice to do a lot of things wow you're
the chef right yes so what you say goes
no should be chef
foreign
[Music]
next ticket Karina please your salad
will be right up full time or part time
it's okay to come in front of customers
or Dave just lets it go on
no it's very gross
and Zach I know you can't tell
Staffordshire but uh this young lady is
chewing gum I just I don't know you're
right yes no I know but um
it's not typical no yes so yeah it's not
typical Laura please shoot this figure
gun out thank you
thank you are you okay yeah I'm fine you
sure yeah you're good what's going on
here yeah you're right she didn't have
done absolutely
excuse me for just one second
want that
what's going with the ribeye Curry then
I'm playing with the second chef but
don't you talk to each other so the food
can hit the window at the same time if
you open up and talk to Art then I can
take the sauce out of the container and
heat it up in a pot yeah Bill Hannah to
me I could do it right here I got lots
of time I'm doing it man for a tiny tiny
chin trying to expedite this food it so
never needs to be this hard you know
that Gina
you don't like talking do you
um it's hard for me when I'm working I'm
sorry but you're doing desserts can't
the young man do the desserts yes I know
everyone tells me I need to relinquish
responsibility guys I'm more capable of
vegan Slice of Cheesecake with these
nice clothes yes chef anyone can do it
but you prefer wasting time doing it
yourself I know it says it couldn't get
any worse the problem with this Lodge is
becoming more apparent there's just no
communication Gina doesn't speak to the
kitchen Dave and Dede ignore the
problems and Zach just doesn't know how
to take him out
oh man so dysfunctional yeah my chicken
is a little cold oh is it
what does she say the chicken breast
chicken is full she's like a new chicken
breast something absolutely
new chicken breast please
just stop for two seconds yes sir
exactly
awesome
well I just want to touch that
touch it it's ice cold ice cold that's
what we resulted in sending you're just
drowned weighing over your head a mess a
big mess m-e-s
oh man
size underwhelmed and disappointed you
build this place to the absolute spec
beyond belief but I was disappointed in
my room the bed's terrible Zach I pulled
back the top duvet and there was blood
underneath the duvet the air
conditioning filters were just full of
[__] it was really shoddy
really shoddy and it broke my heart I
didn't even build the [__] place
and look at the Kitchen Tonight
what I don't get is the service and the
offering
because it was shocking the chicken goes
out ice cold slightly pink and nobody
cares
and that Dreadful cheesecake well that
cheesecake collapsed when I left the
kitchen get rid of it I was I did today
no you didn't I know you
've nuts
you wrote that menu Gina I did you said
your hands were tied so you've got no
Freedom
um Dave gave me more freedom I believe
than he's given chefs in the past so so
you have freak I'm just going on what
you told me I mean no I'm not talking
about chefs and listen you told me
lunchtime your hands were tied and you
can't buy anything you can't talk to
suppliers and what Dave says goes yes I
mean basically Dave do you handcuff Gina
no I'm not handcuffed her only thing I
try to do is get her to cost compare
you've got to try to keep food costs
lower are you telling me that what
you're sending is value for money
it's no it's not nowhere near it am I
the only one that believes what we're
doing is incorrect
Zach you're not a restaurant manager
your heart's not in it young man
and I asked you one vital question
lunchtime if your parents didn't own
this restaurant would you be here and
immediately hell no
I know we're in trouble The Lodges
around here are more successful they're
much more successful and they're not
even half as lovely can I just have five
minutes with you do you mind okay let's
go uh
thank you
[Music]
this is on a deck of cards at the moment
that I feel it's about to collapse
because it's built with no
infrastructure
how's the strain of the business
affected you and Dave
we've had a lot of really really hard
years you know a lot of arguing things
that I think are really important he
doesn't and vice versa why is he so
stubborn in a way that he's so
overbearing and so controlling I think
he's just really scared of
the tries to watch everything you know
you know Dave wanted Zach to kind of
learn the business so that in case
anything happened to him that we didn't
lose everything our kids didn't lose
anything all of our investment right
and you probably know the terrible
things that we went through
well I Disappeared right because I
couldn't function so
he did it all himself he'd run the
Business Without Me and he did the best
he could and
he just did what he has to do and that's
what he does he does what he has
to do and he knew that I was gone and so
he he ran up by himself
in the right place but his head's not in
the game
you've got the view the building's there
but right now it's just a shell it's had
better days for sure really really good
days in the first it was wonderful
we need to get that back
[Music]
good morning good morning I came here
yesterday and I asked everyone to be
open and honest
the first time I heard any honesty last
night was with your mother not easy that
is it
I um don't condone your behavior
my behavior was what
I just felt like you're like the
language that you used wasn't that of an
English gentleman like I would expect
I'm deeply sorry about that what
language did I use a lot of F words
um I don't appreciate you using that
language with my angel of a mother and
my sister could I just stop you there
because you're over exaggerating a
little bit
because I'm not going to give you
brownie points standing in front of your
mother telling me how upset you are when
you're laughing giggling with me at the
same time
you see it as it is you have to call it
as it is I like the fact you're standing
up so it takes me to swear for you to
step up and act like a man
please you don't know [__]
did you just curse that's disgusting
Behavior young man if you want to have a
little chat with me later together
one-on-one I'd love that but stop being
a hypocrite
you've just sworn in front of your
mother that was a mistake and I
apologize mom
the hours you turn in four o'clock in
the afternoon I don't know how you can
call that a full day's work Gina was
frustrated the fact you don't commit
staff get no direction and you walk
around shaking cocktails but I don't
need to prove to you mine does not ask
you to prove it to me
father put you in charge of the
restaurant so the big question is what
is your son Zach doing here my view was
he was going to come
help me run the restaurant
he's not even going to
feedback or talk to Gina or even just
asking service to not chew gum yes it
concerns me great deal Okay so we move
on I've got something really important
to tell you please yes it's something
you're not familiar with
it's called feedback
well let's hear it I spent some time
this morning just traveling around
driving thinking contemplating and
popping into local places fly fishermen
locals houses cabins you name it I went
there at the sad news is they didn't
want to come and sort of
tell you to your face because it's a
small community but I've got the
feedback
my daughter had a wedding reception held
at the lodge we'd go back and celebrate
but over the years things have gone
downhill
Dave makes us very very unwelcome and
he's pushed the town away it doesn't
feel like they want us there
the owners seriously well needs help
he's a total horse's butt he has no idea
how to handle employees or his customers
there was a time the community rallied
round to help them but he showed no
appreciation so it didn't last very long
after time he was a jackass again
couldn't care less too bad so much
potential there maybe they don't care
I don't know why everybody thinks I'm a
horse's ass I guess I am huh
I try to be friendly to people and I
treat them just like I treated you they
come across cold and
arrogant you come across controlling
and you come across assertive yeah we
need to get them on our side whether we
like it or not
their last comment to me was that if you
are prepared to change and commit to
change then they would walk through
those doors
uh Dave I just want to spend a couple of
minutes with you do you mind
thank you guys thank you
why does that get so uh defensive like
that I think insecurity
maybe
um guys can you just give me five
minutes please in fact let's go outside
in fact let's jump in the car
I mean honestly
I'm here to help yeah
you come across so withdrawn I don't
know what to do about that where did
that level of negativity come in well it
started when I first broke ground here
and all the locals started attacking us
and trying to shut us down you know you
have to put your head down start
swinging but then you were successful
you know we were successful and then I
hired a shitty chef and then they all
took off and went away and then I found
a good ship and some of them came back
but I can't
please them all the time sure but it's
not all about the chef Davis you have to
take part of the responsibility you know
so these people leave and they let you
down you know at the end of the day
that's on your shoulders right yes
they dealt with that tragic loss of your
son and that took her a long time did
you seek help when I lost your son no
did who did you talk to no one no one
you just came back into work yeah the
next day the next day there was no one
here
I mean how did you get through how well
I just get through you know
you go day by day time time helps heal
you know but there's a hole in your
heart that never heals right yeah you're
never going to yeah
but have you expressed this to D to him
that that's how you've dealt with it
because I think she's a little bit in
the dark I think she struggles to read
you know maybe I just deal with it by on
a daily basis you know there's not a day
goes by I don't think of my son and the
loss but you know you you move on you
know I still have to make a learning I
still have to take care of DD's feelings
in the kids and all of that you know the
kids got spoiled in the process because
we cuddled them a little bit and that's
obvious and the exact's a product of
that but yeah you know I come from I
believe that they should earn it yeah
but I'm in a situation and I have been
in a situation where my wife doesn't
agree with that philosophy so it's a
constant friction in the same way with
managing our restaurant and our business
she comes in here and wants to coddle
employees and doesn't expect them to
hold to standards and I come in and I
try to get them to hold the standards
and I'm an [__] and we have Conflict
at home so as a result of that I've
tried to minimize the conflicts and let
Zach deal with the restaurant because
that's where most of our conflicts were
the business may have suffered I may
have been an [__] on occasion I don't
know what to do about that you know she
she doesn't understand my personality
but I'm sometimes I take no prisoners
and it offends people indeedy doesn't
understand that mindset she's more of a
all fluff you can't build this thing
like that you're a tough [__] on the
outside you have a heart and you can
show emotion
I have a big heart
then people need to sit
[Music]
um I'd like to talk to you about
something that's been missing
when you built this place we started off
so well didn't we yeah so I've put
something together that I think will
help reinstate that love yeah bring that
back to the Forefront let's have a look
wow who's that there yeah look at that
hair yeah man what happened
look at that
wow
talk about handcrafted even the boys
we've got a little they are yeah that's
rare
Dave's smiley yeah that Israel that that
would have freezed that one there
oh man
incredible
you know sometimes it's easy to forget
this is why you built this amazing Lodge
for the family right Didi yes yeah
chokes me up yeah
look at that that's a picture I haven't
seen forever we need to frame that one
on the wall
[Music]
these are the most amazing pictures
beautiful
something like magical about that first
fish right
Dede we see those amazing pictures what
goes through your mind
oh just
just the memories and dreams that we
have
we have everything just getting better
and better and better you know and
and then just enjoying the property all
of our life right
it's a Stern reminder to why you built
this place and just watching your face
light up reminiscing in some of those
amazing times it's so nice to see yeah
I didn't see it when I arrived
and that's what's been missing yeah
those were good times when we look back
at the pictures that are building the
place it brings back that energy that we
had then and it really does mean
something you know we had we've raised a
family here we've we've raised our kids
here all those memories we're good
memories so it's always been worth
fighting for if for me she needs to fall
back in love with it
but more importantly with each other
yeah
how important is this to you both
it's everything it's the world yeah it's
the world to us that's all we have when
it's done and said you know we spend our
best years building this place and
running it you're confident we can get
back there
you've got it in you
yeah yeah oh I felt so much better
because now we're moving past all the
bad things and we're starting to take a
look towards the good things
after boosting the spirits of DeDe and
Dave it was time to elevate the lodge
itself
my team spent all night working to turn
the Anglers Lodge into a destination
worthy of its Rich family Legacy let's
go I can't wait to show the family what
we've done in you go please
[Music]
enjoy wow look at that come on jump in
oh
oh my gosh wow look at that oh
God Is That Hideous blood color
um inviting gorgeous
let's start off with that amazing
reclaimed wood the bedspreads brand new
oh I love it can you carpets it's just
beautiful is it yeah
I think you've uh you've opened our eyes
to what the place can be it's you've
done a great job
gorgeous beautiful it's amazing it was
just like a new Joy kind of like when we
opened it up the first time it was like
a brand new Joy it's something that we
can reach for after going through such
hard times so we know what to do now
look at the rocking chairs
nice we don't even want to leave
hello hi guys good you guys here to
check in yes great wow oh my gosh hey
Alex how are you good to see you
you should see what they did to the
rooms today it's amazing I've created a
delicious new menu perfect for this
region and my team have been training
the staff non-stop to prepare them for a
successful relaunch tonight here is our
dinner menu I've invited the locals back
and a local food critic so the lodge can
rebuild these important relationships
and get their reputation back on track
everybody's attention just for a second
our critic is sitting watching paying
attention to everything that's going on
thank you
hello we just wanted to welcome you all
to the lodge and I hope you're enjoying
your evening and we appreciate you all
coming in and trying us again and uh
love to have you back can't beat the
setting of course and from now on our
food's going to match all those things
so hope you're having a great time
really nice to have everybody back okay
welcome have a great time
one shortage right up here
what are you doing
right right now it's going
three ribeye
and then you're doing short rib and we
send the appetizers
look look at me
Gina Gina come here man come here you're
not even helping yourself you're not
talking to me are you just going into
one okay I'm gonna force you to talk
Okay so
Gina are you okay I'm okay sure I
promise okay good again out there they
can serve the soup all right would you
please
absolutely okay suit boiling we'll send
the soup with one nice kale salad so
next up art dress me a kale salad no no
I've got the salad okay why can't he
make the salads never asked me this
difficult but you can't work on your own
I've worked on my own many times chef
Gina Gina come here come here
are you listening or you're giving up no
no I know I told you cannot work on your
own you just chat I work on my own all
the time is it best you go now no you
can't work on your eyes you're gonna
sink this place get a grip
okay it's not difficult
next ticket
um yeah FYI and that's nice Gina's
struggling yeah Kurt stepped up art
stepped up uh but with a menu that easy
if your mind's not in that uh you know
you've got no chance
kale salad in the window table 26 seat
one
I did salt pepper
art take over please uh Gina take a step
back art Gina's on the desserts let's go
okay I got chicken in the oven
so were those three apple crisps in the
oven oh you forgot them they are in the
oven Chef yeah uh Donnie reheating a
dessert I expect you to nail that's your
table you know that nice and gently yes
sir off we go
roasted chicken with the crispy skin
and we can't do a scoop of ice cream
no answer we can't do a scoop of ice
cream it's cold in the middle yeah
stop oh you should take your open off
okay go home
art
take over please okay
how's my desserts ready roll
it's not working is it I'm just nervous
no it's not working
you know it's not working
I'm not going to shout I'm not going to
scream it's just it's unfair it's unfair
in you and it's unfair in the lodge
you're sending
a short rib to a table that we haven't
even sent the starters
you're destroying the lot
I've got a Critic that's just landed one
mistake like that and this place is
going to close heard understood I'd like
to finish out the evening and see how it
goes it's not working
if you're going to go back in that
kitchen what are you going to do
differently
what's the point
I want to keep working so that I can get
it down from this thing do not listening
you're not even you're not even prepared
to take any advice any help no it's been
a long time Chef since somebody was
telling me exactly what to do and it's
different for me we can't continue like
this
there's no point of fighting this yeah
sure
oh man okay
[Music]
Dave Gina
speed yeah if you can't work with this
menu it's not going to happen so yeah
the good news is Art and Curt already up
to speed already yeah yeah that's good
uh good feedback for the customers
incredible I'm pretty good he was very
happy he loved everything's compliments
all around not a single complaint
straight any difficult questions on the
critic nothing different at all no he
was uh he's very friendly very nice and
just really enjoying everything he's
like this was simple and it was
beautiful it was perfect awesome nice
good night right it was really good
happy I am happy very happy that's nice
I'm just so happy to have it that's so
nice to see you back in here yeah well I
mean they're happy right yeah that's the
most important thing but there's one
tiny Missing Link
someone that I've arranged for all three
of you to meet her background is
extraordinary she knows the area inside
out and I've asked her to come here for
a month and help set this place up and I
want you to benefit from her knowledge
please welcome Emily Brown how are you
I'm Emily Beauty pleasure Zach hi Emily
nice to meet you today welcome nice to
see you welcome well good to see you
um first of all she knows this business
inside out and it's excited work as a
consultant for a month and help set this
place up for a very very busy season
yeah I've heard all about you guys
really excited to get you guys where you
really need to be so welcome
um I want you two to do something you
haven't done for a long time I'd like
you to take your dear lady and go and
have dinner oh that is won't that be
nice tonight Zach's got a table for you
oh that'd be great excellent it's the
first time I'm holding hands oh
my God yeah
I think Dave's smiling it's like the
pressure's lifted off
the love is rekindled for sure
and I'm really excited to have everybody
in Island Park start coming back again
and being excited about the logic they
were when we first built it
uh my time is done
you guys have a great spark here trust
me you need to show it don't stop good
night take care God bless thanks bye
thank you so much
cheers
yeah to a new Lodge
wow what a nice
that's better
man that's cold out there
there's a [__] handbrake
gear stick on the steering wheel
[Music]
I shouldn't drive [__] useless
[Laughter]
after I left the lodge
the family embraced the many changes and
is excited about the future
both Didi and Dave have rekindled their
passion you're doing good honey we're a
good team and I'm enjoying working
together to make Anglers Lodge the place
to be once again